[MUSIC]
As I started speaking, what was
the first thing you noticed about me?
Was it my charming smile, my charismatic
personality, or was it my accent?
Having lived in the US now for
almost three years,
I realized that for
a lot of people, it is my accent.
I come from Pakistan, which is why I
have an unmistakable South Asian accent.
I've been fascinated by accents for
many years.
First because, well, we all have one.
Second, I feel strongly about how
a person's unique accent can trigger
people's conscious and unconscious biases
and lead to accent discrimination.
Research has shown that we're less
likely to believe something if it is
said with a foreign accent.
These negative judgments are the result of
the additional effort their brains must
make to process foreign speech.
Our brains then shift the blame for
this additional effort on to
the truthfulness of the speaker.
And it can trigger frustration.
About a year ago, I was on the phone
with my health insurance company for
some information I needed
before an upcoming trip.
I had been on the call for almost an hour,
hopping from one call agent to another
without any solution to my problem.
I was becoming more and more impatient.
I was then redirected for the fourth time.
And as the new call
agent started speaking,
I instantly noticed
a distinct East Asian accent,
perhaps Chinese or Korean,
and I exploded internally.
I don't need this accent right now.
I didn't say this to her, of course,
but that's what I thought.
My frustration was caused
by my complete inability
to understand anything she was saying.
And then I stopped.
At that point, it hit me I was
doing exactly what I've been so
strongly opposed to.
I was allowing someone's accent
to influence how I saw them,
how I listened to them,
how I treated them.
That day, I was able to learn
what I felt deeply about for
many years, accent empathy.
I define accent empathy as thinking
deeper about how a person's
unique accent is a manifestation
of their lived experience,
of their cultural identity,
of their humanity.
Growing up in Pakistan, I saw
firsthand how perfecting your English
proficiency was seen as much more
than just language acquisition.
It was a symbol of status,
of ability, of sophistication.
This is the legacy of 200
years of British colonialism.
Mastery of spoken English was what
separated the colonial masters
from their Indian subjects.
This gave rise to the brown Sahibs,
Indians who yearn to imitate the British
in language, dress or lifestyle,
because doing so conferred patronage
from the colonial government.
Even years after the British
left the Indian subcontinent,
this English centered indoctrination
was still alive and well.
I grew up seeing adults and
children giggle at and even openly insult
people who spoke broken English or
mispronounce an English word.
And the opposite was also true, speaking
fluent with perfect pronunciation and
good accents give you prestige.
My high school debate coach
once said to our entire team,
all of you need to fix your
accent except Mansoor.
I'd be lying if I said I didn't
feel immense pride at that point.
It may seem to be misplaced
pride in retrospect, but
then in that moment, my pride was real.
Yet this reinforced within me a certain
toxic complex and insecurity.
I had to protect my accent.
As I traveled to places outside
of Pakistan, I began to realize
that mastery of a language or
accent is not a sign of competence.
I began to accept my accent as
part of who I am, of my identity.
Then I came to the US and suddenly
found myself in the odd position of
the guy with the different foreign accent.
Sometimes when I spoke in Zoom meetings,
I was met with complete silence.
The group, all native English speakers,
would move on to speaking
amongst themselves.
Why was this happening?
Did they disagree with
the substance of what I'd said?
Was it Zoom fatigue?
Was it my accent?
I could only speculate.
But this did take a toll on me.
I felt overlooked, dismissed, invisible.
Fortunately for me,
by this stage of my life,
I genuinely began to
cherish my unique accent.
I'm not making a political
statement of any sort.
I truly cherish my Pakistani accent as a
symbol of my life journey and my identity,
I value it as an expression of love for
my family, my grandparents, my home.
But accent discrimination is real.
According to research at
Curtin University in Australia,
there is a hierarchy that places American,
British, and Australian English
accent at the top, views European
accented English as cute or stylish.
But Asian or
African accents as ugly and unpleasant.
The UK is known to view specific accents
as working class versus sophisticated.
Former British Prime Minister,
Margaret Thatcher had to lose the
Lincolnshire accent to sound more posh.
In the US,
the story is a bit more nuanced.
Lauren Rivera in her book, Pedigree,
writes that accents play a role in
shaping recruitment at elite firms.
According to Rivera,
interviewers frequently questioned the
polish of foreign students of all races,
complaining that most candidates' accents
made them difficult to understand.
Exceptions were those with pure British,
German or Scandinavian accents.
This is the accent hierarchy at work.
There's also anti black
racism in linguistics,
something that even former First Lady
Michelle Obama had to contend with.
And she's a Harvard educated lawyer.
But I believe that we owe it to ourselves,
and to each other,
to put in that little extra effort
to move beyond any cognitive and
intellectual laziness that
might be stifling us.
So the next time you find yourself
struggling to engage with someone having
an unfamiliar accent,
I challenge you to pause.
Take a deep breath.
Ask yourself,
why am I having such a reflexive reaction?
Is it just because the accent
is different from my own?
Think about what your accent
says about you, your family,
your festivals, your aspirations,
your struggles, your identity.
Do you really want to rob
someone of the same just so
you can save a few
seconds of mental energy.
That, to me, is accent empathy in action.
And if you truly aspire to change
lives and change organizations in
an increasingly interconnected world,
we need accent empathy.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]